hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round five of
the online features that combinations
Cup in a game between wonho and Fabiana
Caruana so to two participants of the
2020 candidates tournament
fabbi playing board one for the United
States and one called board one for
China well switching it up between him
and the ding Liron but before we check
it out as as the the thumbnail suggests
we do have some drama in the chess world
so here is the tweet says that calm
published regarding madness madness
cross and not participating in the event
they say many chest fans have been
wondering why Magnus Carlsen isn't
playing in the feed a chess come online
Nations Cup here is why of course we
would have loved to have Magnus compete
comments purchase that comes Nick Barton
so as a feeder event all player invites
for the online Nations Cup were handled
solely by feeding Magnus was invited to
participate in this historic tournament
and we would have loved to have him take
part in it unfortunately though an offer
to play was extended by each of Fida
director-general Amos Otis gainfully
President Arkady dvorkovich our
understanding is that Magnus was not
willing to play under the same financial
financial conditions as the other
participants we have the utmost respect
for Magnus's talent and he will continue
to receive invites the chest that comes
events on a regular basis just as he has
for many years however Magnus was not
very happy with with this tweet and well
published a tweet of his own saying that
thanks for putting up a very
entertaining event and letting me know
that I will be invited to events in the
future
now that you have outed me as a greevey
i will ask for at least triple what I
would have asked this time though so
obviously I will not obviously but it's
hard to say why he isn't playing or what
was the problem with did he offer maybe
maybe he just wasn't offered enough
money to take part in this event but I
remember hearing him mention this in
during one of his streams that he
mentioned something like if I'm not
playing for Norway there's no Norway
amongst the nations I don't really feel
like representing Europe so I decided
not to take part that's that's how I
remember so I don't know what happened
here but I'm sure we're gonna
I hear a lot more about it so for those
of you who are not on Twitter I will
shed some light on the matter in the
days to come
so getting back to the game Ivanka with
the white pieces opens with Knight to f3
we have the rate the opening and
immediately d5 which is my favorite
reply to the ready
we have g3 and now immediately Bishop to
g4 which is which is a fine way to play
against that eighty as you immediately
figure out a way how to develop your
lights work better
we have Bishop the g2 and now Knight to
d7 we're going for the Icarus variation
against the other eighty we have castles
and east six by favi we have d3 and the
Bishop to d6 now Knight B to d2 end here
in Knight to e7 preparing to castle
sorry and that Knight B to d2 not Bishop
to b2 and the Knights the e7 preparing
to castle and now h3i asking do you
wanna trade or do you want to go back
Fabi goes back and now b3 one call
prepares to feel care to the dark square
Bishop is well we have castles by Fabia
now a bishop to beat you and here there
is one game in the database where c6 was
played but here Fabi goes for a5 and it
is already as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game so Vaughn cow also
goes a 4 prevents further expansion from
Fabian on the Queen side and now c5
grabbing more space in the center we've
G for Bishop to g6 and now 92 h4 so here
Ivanka expanded his pawns in front of
the King which kind of makes his King a
bit more more vulnerable but he wants to
win the bishop pair so Fabi continues
with Knight to c6
I just puts the pieces on optimal
squares and now Knight captures here we
have H captures in the now efore Fabi
decides to close the center would be 4
which puts this dark square Bishop out
of commission for the moment and f4 now
so here Ivanka really controls a lot of
squares here so far we finds a way to
immediately tackle that and well fight
for the control of the e5 square by
directly challenging DF for pawn so here
you either capture or or you play e5 or
we play f5 long how has to decide how to
deal with this he decides to go for f5
and now Bishop to f/4 by favi we have
Knight to c4 and here comes e5 which is
a bit odd well probably not as Fabi is a
very strong player I would imagine the
night would come here to trade off a
pair of nights at least before going if
I've since by pushing if I right away
it's hard to hard to decide where these
Knights are going but Bobby has it all
figured out
we have brush up to see one now
preparing to get rid of this strong
Bishop and rook the a6 now the rock will
know in the future you will be able to
shift it over to the Kings side if the
knight moves you can even go to b6 if
needed and and so on so Queen e2 and now
Queen to e7 developing the Queen we have
Queen to f2 keeping an eye on the h4
Square in the future you might want to
start pushing with h4 and now Knight the
be 400k this Knight found I found a nice
outpost we still need to figure out
where this night is going so here among
how traits the bishops with Bishop
captures an F for G captures in the now
H for the Queen from f2 nicely guards
the h4 Square and now Bobby does not
want to allow g5 f 6 and for Vaughn hard
to start pushing on the King side so
instead Fabi pushes g5 where he will be
very happy with a captures capture
scenario or so instead among how it goes
for F captors and g6 Alba song and now
comes F captures on g6 and now just g5
now so long how says this will give my
bishop some new life I can switch it
over to this diagonal we have night the
b6 now trying to trade off this night as
one house night on c4 is also on an
excellent outpost and Bishop to f3 now
first we have Knight captures on c4 b
captors and c4 and now rook to b6 and
now that the knight moves you could
maybe infiltrate the position through
through the Queen side but rook F the b1
now saying your knight is not going
anywhere as your rook here is is
undefended so here Bobby needs to find a
way how to play this he's definitely
better as a white really doesn't have
much to go on but trying to but through
it to create some sort of a breakthrough
and the Kings that would be very
dangerous this case his King is still
also on the Kings side so here Bobby
starts
shifting the king over to the Queen side
first King g7 we have King to g2 now
rook to h8 now putting pressure on this
pawn here we have Bishop to g4 and now
King to f8 so so basically again
artificially castling we have looked the
b3 with ideas of doubling up on the B
file but now King EA and here Fabi wants
to shift his skin all the way to the
Queen side keep the Queen side closed
with the knight nicely placed on before
and then go for a breakthrough on the
Kings side we have King f3 and now came
to d8 we worked h1 now and quinta e8
now if h5 is played you have additional
support for CalPERS on h5
we have worked back to a 1x1 car and
came to c7 now we have King to g2 and
now kink the b8 and one how repeats came
to a3 saying that I've got nothing
better
and now Fabi as the the King is nicely
safe and on the Queen side he wants to
bring the rook into the game as the
knight really prevents or any play
whatsoever on the Queen side so rook c6
preparing to shifted the rook over to
the Queen so King side and now rook be
back to be 1 the rook will also need to
help out with the defense of the Kings
side we have rook c7 and now rook the h1
we have rook Seeta h7 and now rook the
h2 Queen to c6 and now you can bring the
other rope over here because you still
need to keep an eye on a four point if
you lose the e4 pawn then it's just bad
so here you have to either repeat moves
as something like rook h1 work to h3 and
try and hold on to see what what Fabi
has in mind but one cow went for a
different idea he played the active h5
however this doesn't really work because
Bobby just captures it and after Bishop
to a5 we have looked to g7 and now g6
and it seems like a blockade has been
created here you can start bringing your
queen int again into the game as well
but there is a problem as the position
is now completely lost for one call so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this only move that wins the game
for Fabi
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the only
move that wins the game for black and
for those of you that just want to enjoy
the show
it's rook to f8 rook the f8
the idea being rook captures Bishop an
f5 as the Epona spendy will not be able
to capture back and there's no good move
for white there's no square for the
bishop for example if you go back Bishop
h3 let's say then just will capture sin
g6 you've lost another pawn and rook the
g3 check is coming the other route can
double up it's just game over for white
another thing you might try is to unpin
the king for example you can't go
anywhere over here so might you might
play king e2 but then you lose the c2
point as the Queen no longer defends it
so again your position will just fall
apart the knight can go back you've lost
another pawn that's just no way to play
so instead Vanko said okay rook captures
an h5 I'm just gonna defend my bishop so
it's not a problem or is it a problem
because Fabi played rook captures on f5
and now the point is still pinned so of
course one cop captured it with a rook
but now Queen captures on g6 and now all
of a sudden fabi's down the exchange but
he's threatening Queen to g4 checkmate
so you have to try something along her
play the Queen to h2 he freed the DF to
square for his King but now again now
once again pause the video and try to
find the winning idea now for Fabi while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that the pawn
on c2 is actually a free pawn and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show it's nice captures and c2 just
removing the fender of the d3 pawn and
now basically the idea is the knight
back Knight captures here and White's
position just crumbles point is if you
capture it it's a force checkmate Queen
g3 check King has to go to e2 Queen e3
check King d1 or f1 doesn't really
matter and then just rook the g1
checkmate so evanka of course could not
capture the night he played rook the h1
as the rook on a1 was also under attack
but here we have Queen to g4 check King
to have to end the now just Knight back
the b4 and it was in this position and
move 46 that one how I resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the d3 pawn will
fall there's no way you can defend that
you can't go near it with the king
rugby one is impossible because of just
Queen captures so there are no moves
here for white you can just wait for for
Fabi to you know have his way with you
so to say so yeah very nice 46 move game
Vanka tried to try to you know endure it
and keep everything close but Fabi found
this well he shouldn't have put the h5
point then maybe he would have chances
but after that Fabi found Roca fate and
it was all downhill from there so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Frank combs david
benedict oliver choice for thomas
Conners and Dwight Berkeley for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos ER thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the nation's
Cup and whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and do join us in the tournaments
today the links are in the description
below as usual every Friday
see you soon